this video is sponsored by brilliant
you notice that the language around
climate keeps changing first it was
global warming then it was climate
change and now it's the climate crisis
and just recently United Nations
Secretary General Antonio guteresh
referred to Global boiling doesn't this
indicate that scientists don't know what
they're doing and they're just trying to
whip up fear no the language around
climate is very carefully Chosen and has
evolved for a very good reason in don't
even think about it Author George
Marshall describes climate change as a
quote perfect problem an issue is
challenging enough if it concerns only
losses and no gains and it is
challenging if those losses are
long-term not short-term and it is
challenging if it has substantial
uncertainty climate change appears to be
the perfect combination of all three
factors which makes it so incredibly
difficult to respond to effectively
except as Marshall talks about in the
book that is only the case if we frame
the problem and our response to it in
those terms I highly recommend everyone
reads this by the way I'll leave a link
in the description a key point that
Marshall makes is that language matters
in order to make people care about and
take action on climate change an issue
that is intangible largely slow and yet
incredibly serious scientists need to
use the most precise language to elicit
a response when scientists initially
started talking about human emissions of
carbon dioxide heating up the planet the
phrase global warming seemed to be the
right one because the planet was on
average warming up but the problem was
it wasn't doing so uniformly as became
clear weather extremes were shifting
some places saw more extreme cold or
more or less rainfall it wasn't just
warming when these events took place
people quite reasonably asked what about
global warming my average weather just
got colder or unreasonably said so much
for global warming it just snowed in my
job I think of this meme quite a lot so
to better reflect the changing climate
which was on average but not everywhere
warming scientists started using the
phrase climate change in terms of
people's lived reality it was more
accurate and so in theory would lead to
Greater believability of scientists and
so make people more likely to heed their
warnings but it isn't just about
accuracy it's one thing to make people
aware of an issue it's something
entirely different to make them want to
do something about it and the science is
very clear we do need to do something
about climate change or suffer serious
consequences and here we enter the murky
realm of psychology
[Music]
want someone to do something is it more
effective to make them afraid of the
consequences of not doing it or show
them the benefits of doing it in other
words which emotion is more likely to
make them do the thing fear or hope to
test this at an event that I recently
hosted I presented my audience with two
headlines about climate change in the
21st century one based around fear and
one based around hope put up your hand
if you think the first statement is more
compelling
okay and now put up your hand if you
think the second statement is more
compelling okay interesting pretty
clearly my audience found the positive
statement with connotations of Hope more
engaging than the negative statement
with connotations of fear of course
however I'm not the first person to do
this kind of experiment there is an
extensive academic literature on the
subject of emotive language and climate
change and asking which emotions are
most effective at inducing an audience
to take action on climate the conclusion
of this literature is that things are a
bit more complicated than just good
emotion good bad emotion bad as became
clear at the event when I asked people
why they found a certain statement more
compelling than the other all doesn't
work we are standing
why do you think that first statement is
more component it shows a supervision of
the situation so 1.5 degrees doesn't
really mean anything for most people
especially because it's an average they
don't realize that there's two extremes
negative emotions work way more harder
than positive ones especially when
you're trying to paint people pay
attention to myself call to actions time
is running out whereas the next one is
like still time to limit so it's like
then the second ones it feels more like
fluffy and rounded to me I feel like the
lowercase s also yeah
foreign
about climate change so it's nice to
actually have something positive and I
think that would catch another side of
people that want to want to take action
not only is it more hopeful there's also
Solutions Doom scrolling is Enough Of
Our Lives that we don't need to add more
to it blurs into the background the
decision makers who
they need to know
can be done the second one feels we're
like okay there's still time we can
still do something I'm going to engage
in this
brilliant so I think I think it's very
interesting that for some people hope is
a more powerful emotion and for some
people it's fear like it's very it's
like a Jedi Sith kind of device
The crucial takeaway from my event and
from the literature is that the same
language hits differently with different
cultures with different groups of people
when talking about climate change the
emotion most likely to inspire action in
an audience will vary depending on the
audience in one culture the emotion most
likely to inspire action on climate is
fear in another it might be anger in
another it might be hope it's why fear
Laden books like the uninhabitable Earth
will resonate with some audiences but
actively turn off others and the same
for hopeful books like the future we
choose the net effect of a particular
narrative could be negative depending on
the emotion news the size of the target
culture and how the narrative will be
perceived by other groups who hear it in
any form of communication it is
imperative to have your target audience
in Mind by trying to talk to everyone at
once you talk to no one effectively it's
why top level climate communication from
bodies like the UN and the ipcc is so
difficult and why it quite frequently
misses The Mark with at least some
cultures for example when guteresh said
the phrase Global boiling it effectively
engaged some people but it was actively
damaging to the engagement of others who
said that the language was inaccurate
and sensationalist marketing 101 Target
your language to your target audience
something made much more difficult in an
age of social media when every message
ends up spreading everywhere so what
does this mean for how scientists and
activists should talk to the public
about climates well it will vary Case by
case there's no one-size-fits-all
approach in some cases you are more
likely to inspire action on climate
change by making your target audience
angry about how costly inaction so far
has proven as was shown in a study in
Norway in other cases it would be more
effective to make your audience want to
build new green infrastructure to
provide hope of a better future as will
likely be the case with a younger
audience suffering from climate anxiety
ultimately you just have to know your
audience the undercurrent of all this
however is one more Factor
I mentioned previously that the language
we use to describe the problem of and
solution to climate change is incredibly
important not just because it determines
the type of response we have to the
problem but it also determines the
nature of the problem itself there's
this phenomenal quote from the late
great Archbishop Desmond Tutu speaking
about apartheid in South Africa this is
one of my all-time favorite quotes
language is very powerful language does
not just describe reality language
creates the reality it describes the
critical issue is time the science is
unequivocal that we have a narrowing
window to avoid causing significant
irrevocable damage to the world we
depend on for our survival no matter
what emotion we want an audience to feel
when discussing climate we need them to
know that now is the time for action now
is the time to put whatever emotion they
are feeling into effect and this is why
climate change has become the climate
crisis I think it's a very carefully and
very accurately chosen word to
articulate the time and sensitivity of
our response and by using it we create
the reality that necessitates an
immediate response of course that
reality isn't being created it already
exists just to an omnipresent being that
can somehow feel all the data sets that
scientists have collected over decades
to be very clear I'm not talking about
manufacturing a reality that matches
what scientists want people to think
we're talking about creating a human
accessible reality Bound by the
limitations of human experiences and
human language a representation of a
global problem far beyond any
individual's experiences and yet one
that we must grasp what form that
representation takes will depend on the
audience you're talking to but the
common factor between all
representations is just how little time
we have considering the expected impact
of inaction calling it a climate crisis
is accurate it conveys severity and the
need for immediate action but it's just
a name how we use that name and how we
refer to our actions to address the
climate crisis cannot be determined in a
one-size-fits-all approach our language
must be tailored to the audience we wish
to reach forming a multitude of climate
realities described in media so if
you've noticed that the language around
climate has changed that's because the
climate has changed and as the window
for Meaningful action Narrows the need
for tailored emotive language around
climate becomes ever greater climate
communication is only going to get more
sophisticated and more diverse from here
yeah because
it has to using dry scientific language
didn't work and so scientists now are
forced to use the full gamut of emotive
language to inspire the action that we
as a global Society need to take if you
would like to put the headlines around
climate change into context whatever
language they use then you could do with
a primer on climate or statistics or
solar energy fortunately fun and free
courses on those subjects and many more
are available on brilliant who have
kindly sponsored this video brilliant is
the best way to learn maths science and
computer science interactively there are
hundreds of lessons accessible via
browser or their app are built around
the concept of engaging a student
introducing New Concepts and then
immediately getting you to apply them
for example their new course on
exploring data visually introduces you
to a data set of Starbucks cafes and
then examines how to most effectively
slice and represent this data you are
involved from the very beginning if
you're looking to improve your
understanding of how scientists talk
about the natural world through
statistics and through equations then I
cannot recommend brilliant highly enough
their courses are gorgeous they're
constantly being updated and they're
based on the principle that I think is
most effective when it comes to
individual learning you can get access
to brilliant for free for a full 30 Days
by visiting brilliant.org Simon Clark or
clicking the link in the description the
first 200 of you to do so will also get
20 off brilliant's annual premium
subscription that's brilliant.org Simon
Clark with thanks to brilliant for
sponsoring this video
thank you so much for watching the video
I really hope you enjoyed it if you were
inspired by the use of language around
climate change I would highly recommend
don't even think about it the book I
mentioned at the start of the video
please do check out the description for
a link to that as well as a link of
course to brilliant also down there in
the description you'll find a link to my
patreon if you would like to support me
making more videos get access to behind
the scenes content and have a say in
some of the topics that I cover then you
can support me at patreon.com forward
slash simonoxvis these people on screen
right now are my lovely executive
producer patrons who support me at the
top tier thank you so much for making
this work possible if you enjoyed the
video you know what to do popular like
share it comment you've been on YouTube
before that just leads me to say if
you'd like to watch something else
here's some recommended viewing next
thank you again so much for watching and
I'll see you in the next one